S
KNOWN FOR MANY YEARS, EVEN
BEFORE HE BECAME PRESIDENT.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> DO YOU TALK TO OBAMA STILL?
>> I WAS OBAMA'S FAVORITE
ARTIST.
OBAMA MET WITH ME AND MY MAMA TO
SAY THAT HE WAS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE BACK IN 2008.
AND THAT HE WANTED THE SUPPORT.
EVERYBODY WAS SO INTO THIS IDEA
OF A BLACK PRESIDENT.
WE WERE ALWAYS COOL.
IT'S ALSO LIKE HOW MANY OF US
ARE THERE?
YOU KNOW, OBAMA LEVEL, YE LEVEL,
VIRGIL LEVEL?
JUST BLACK, SO BRILLIANT THAT WE
CUT THROUGH ALL OF THE LINES OF
RACISM.
YOU JUST CAN'T GET RID OF US.
NAT KING COLE LEVEL.
DAVE CHAPELLE LEVEL.
SOME PLAYS WE WOULD HAVE TO BE
FRIENDS TO GET ALONG.
YOU ARE AT THAT LEVEL.
YOU ARE FORMULA ONE LEWIS
HAMILTON RACECAR DRIVER.
YOU ARE STILL DRIVING A WHITE
CAR, BUT WE ARE THE BEST RACECAR
DRIVERS THAT EVER EXISTED.
THAT WAS ME AND OBAMA'S
CONNECTION.
BUT HE WASN'T SAYING THE THINGS
I WAS SUPPOSED TO SAY AS A
RAPPER.
OUR CONNECTION FADED.
>> YOU DON'T TALK TO HIM
ANYMORE?
>> I WILL TALK TO HIM IF I SEE
HIM.
BUT I GUARANTEE WHEN HE SEES ME,
I JUST THOUGHT THAT SOUNDED
COOL.
ONE IDEA THAT WAS IN MY HEAD
ABOUT THREE MINUTES AGO THAT I
REALLY WANT TO SAY THAT IS
REALLY INTERESTING ABOUT WHEN
COMPANIES GET THE BLM MANAGERS.
>> WHAT IS A BLM MANAGER?
>> BLACK LIVES MATTER OFFICE
MANAGER.
IT'S BASICALLY YOU GET A SEMI
INFLUENTIAL BLACK PERSON TO
BECOME THE FACE OF A WHITE
COMPANY.
THAT MEANS IN THE DESIGN WORLD,
IN THE ART WORLD, THEY ACTUALLY
WILL PICK ARTISTS THAT WERE LESS
TALENTED THAN OTHER ARTISTS
BASED ON THEIR INFLUENCE, NOT
BASED ON THEIR ACTUAL WORK.
BECAUSE EVERYONE IS VYING FOR
INFLUENCE AND AN OPINION.
EVERYONE IS AFRAID OF LOSING
THEIR OPINION.
>> WITH NIKE, WRIGHT, NIKE IS AS
FAMOUS.
YOU SAY NIKE IS MORE FAMOUS THAN
PAYPAL, RIGHT?
WHAT NUMBER COMPANY DO YOU THINK
PAYPAL IS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> NUMBER 4.
>> OVERALL?
>> OVERALL.
YOU KNOW THE NUMBER ONE IS
APPLE.
I FORGET NUMBER 2.
BUT NUMBER THREE IS MCDONALD'S,
THEN SPACEX IS MAYBE SIX OR
SEVEN.
IT'S INTERESTING IN THAT AS LIT
AS ELON MUSK IS HIS PREVIOUS
COMPANY IS STILL WORTH MORE THAN
SPACEX.
WHAT NUMBER COMPANY DO YOU THINK
NIKE IS?
NUMBER 321.
IT IS NOT THERE.
TO BE AS BIG A FINANCIAL COMPANY
AS IT CAN BE.
IT IS THERE AN INFLUENCER
BECAUSE BLACK PEOPLE LOVE NIKE.
SO NIKE IS LIKE A COMPANY THAT
IS REDLINING AND GERRYMANDERING
BLACK PEOPLE.
SO THE REASON WHY GAP WANTED ME
TO GO TO A GAP WASN'T BASED ON
WE NEED TO GET OUR STOCKS UP.
IT'S LIKE THESE COMPANIES WHEN
THEY HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG
TIME, GAP RAN THE TRADE.
WE WILL NEVER BE APPLE.
ALL OF THESE AMERICAN COMPANIES
SOMEHOW TIPPED THIS DEAL WHERE
THEY START PUTTING IN THESE
REALLY AWKWARD AND WEIRD NUMBER
KIND OF CEOS.
NIKE HAS GOT ONE.
THE GAP HAD ONE.
IT DIDN'T WORK OUT.
IT'S ALL OF THESE WEIRD
OPERATORS INSIDE OF COMPANIES.
EVEN IN BALENCIAGA.
THEY ARE JUST THERE FOR CONTROL.
STEVE JOBS TALKED ABOUT IT.
IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
YOU CAN HAVE, CONTROL.
LOOK AT ME.
ALL THE MONEY, ALL THE INFLUENCE
AND I HAVE TO ACT A COMPLETE ASS
TO HAVE ANY SAY SO OF ANYTHING
THAT MY CHILDREN ARE DOING
BECAUSE THAT GROUP OF PEOPLE
HAVE CONTROL AND SAY SO OVER ALL
THE CHILDREN INSIDE OF THE CLAN.
SO THAT'S WHAT THESE COMPANIES
ARE SET UP FOR.
THAT'S THE TYPE OF CEOS THEY ARE
HIRING.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE FOUNDERS ARE
OUT OF THERE, THEY GIVE THE
COMPANIES UP TO A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE AND THEY ARE ALL IN
CAHOOTS LIKE ANYONE THAT EVER
WORKED WITH ME.
THEY JUST LOOK AND SAY WHO IS YE
FARMING FOR TALENT THAT WE CAN
HIRE TO BE OUR NEW BLM OFFICE
MANAGER?
KIND OF LIKE OBAMA.
>> YOU THINK OF OBAMA AS A BLM
OFFICE MANAGER?
>> THAT'S WHATEVER.
THAT'S WHATEVER.
I THINK OBAMA, JUST LIKE VIRGIL,
THESE PEOPLE WERE TRULY BLACK TO
THEIR CORE AND TRULY BRILLIANT
TO THEIR CORE, BUT THEY WENT
INTO SITUATIONS THINKING THAT
THEY COULD DO WITH THE WHITES
WAY AS A BLACK MAN.
WE SAW WHAT COLOR OBAMA'S HAIR
COLOR WAS WHEN HE WENT IN AND
WHAT COLOR IT WAS WHEN HE WENT
OUT.
VIRGIL LOST ALL HIS HAIR.
AND EVENTUALLY PASSED AWAY.
WHEN I HAVE TECHNIQUES THAT ARE
REVOLUTIONARY, IF I RAISE MY
VOICE AND EXPRESS MYSELF ON
INSTAGRAM, IT'S A AND PEOPLE CAN
SAY THIS WHAT YOU ARE DOING IS
TOXIC.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS TOXIC, I'VE
GOT TO DO EVERYTHING TO GET IT
OUT OF MY BODY AND THERE WILL BE
TIMES WHEN I SEE A LEVEL OF
OPPRESSION, PARISIAN PROPER,
NEXT LEVEL FRANCE OWNS 80% OF
AFRICAN BANKS LEVEL,
COLONIZATION OPPRESSION AND I
WILL BE LIKE I AM NOT GOING TO
LET YOU GUYS KILL ME.
BUT NUMBER ONE THING THAT HAS TO
REALLY HAPPEN, SAY IF TRUMP RAN,
RIGHT?
WE ARE NOT JUST GOING TO BE
BLACK INFLUENCE.
WE ARE GOING TO BE VISION AND
CREATIVITY.
WE HAVE GOT TO RETHINK WHO WE
ARE AS A SPECIES.
WRIGHT NOW, WE PRACTICE KILLING
IT OURSELVES EVERY DAY.
LIKE MURDER IS LEGAL IN AMERICA.
>> EVEN ABORTION?
>> YES.
>> WHOEVER GETS THE POSITION
NEEDS TO LISTEN TO THE VISION.
I DIDN'T KNOW I WAS GOING TO
RHYME WHEN I FIRST STARTED.
THEY NEED TO HAVE ELON.
THEY NEED TO HAVE ME.
YOU SHOULD START WITH THOSE TWO
AND THEN WE WILL GET TO THE REST
OF THEM.
YOU CAN PULL AND JOHNNY AND ALL
OF THE LIVING, SUPER BRILLIANT
PEOPLE.
WE NEED TO ANALYZE AND NOT JUST
SELL OUT FOR THE CASH.
THESE FORTUNE 500 COMPANIES ARE
JUST SELLING OUT FOR THE CASH.
PUT GOD FIRST AND THE BEST
REPRESENTATION OF GOD IS THE
CHILDREN.
THE CHILDREN IS EXTENSION OF
FAMILY.
BUT THE FAMILIES FIRST.
THERE SO MANY THINGS.
THE SUBURBS.
THE TRAIN TRACKS BEING RIPPED UP
BY GM JUST FOR CAPITALISM.
ALL THESE IDEAS THAT WE HAVE.
WE ARE NOW LIVING IN A PLACE
WHERE WE ARE THE ORPHANS OF
CAPITALISM AND WE HAVE TO TAKE A
PAUSE AND RETHINK HOW WE CAN
HAVE THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
EXISTENCE POSSIBLE FOR OUR
CHILDREN, FO